now i would like to welcome dr raja
vargaman so to expand further on the
topics that were discussed by dr nidhi
and the panel discussion
dr raja vadman is the senior
bioinformatics specialist at prima's
life sciences and spends most of his
time analyzing and reporting cancer
genomic data sets from illumina
platforms and hospitals like cochlear
vein and they are cancer institute who
he has published his cancer studies in
american molecular pathology journals
journal of molecular and genetic
medicine and has trained several
institutes in india
which were involved in major genomic
programs like sarso surveillance he has
also written several articles on diverse
topics focusing on clinical informatics
comprehensive genomic profiling
nutrigenomics and infectious diseases
and different magazines blocks etc he
previously has had exposure to precision
medicine and non-clinical sequencing
data analysis while he was working with
several bioinformatics companies we are
pleased to have you with us mr raja over
to you
thank you so much for uh that very
detailed introduction and thank you so
much for the given chance let me share
the screen
somehow i feel my topic is being stolen
by the previous uh
panelist
uh
keeping that aside uh i might reiterate
the same thing in a different form
altogether
let's see how much it reaches
without any further due my name is raj
verman kittu i'm working as a
bioinformatics specialist in premars
life sciences today we are going to see
the technical skills as well as the soft
skills which is needed to be in industry
again
it's not specific to informatics i would
probably consider this as a
recommendation for any technical uh
probably the id or
the bioinformatics together right
wherever the data analysis comes in
picture this can be applied
so three things we're going to discuss
first is technical skills and then soft
skills and the mindset pretty much all
these topics are covered by the previous
panelist but
i will be adding little more extra
points here
so speaking about technical skills there
are some unique skills comes with
certain people and as a team we need to
have some specific sales probably i
would say
people specific skills as well as the
team management skills right so
currently we are going to see uh first
let's focus on individual skills suppose
the given problem
yes so say in the informatics generally
in the i.t related companies or the
informatics companies you'll be given a
problem or will be asking to develop a
tool so those kind of situations first
we need to understand the problem was
basically what you want to do either we
want to do the analysis for the given
data sets or we want to build some
software and then we'll be going for the
plan like say the architecture
like clear plan on the architecture the
second one is what are the
infrastructure we need then how many
manpowers we need how many people and
where are the resources has to be
put on right and the last one is time
frame and then finally we'll be deciding
what are my deliverables and how fast i
can give so this is a basic benchmark or
probably the need
or the workflow which has to be followed
right in both the cases
so be it it's happening on the cloud or
local this is the ultimate goal for any
given cases right
say we are going to develop a product
say be a software product which is being
done in the local or you are developing
a product in the cloud or you are
developing a database altogether right
or there are some cases since currently
people are so much fond of going for uh
artificial intelligence or machine
learning or probably the svm is one of
the classical machine learning
techniques neural network concept or
deep learning concept
any of those cases apart from even the
data management first of all we need to
understand what is a given problem or
the situation come up with a detailed
plan and we need to know the logic as
well before even starting any given
coding we need to know the logic we need
to convert the whole problem into the
scripting language by the way we need to
be very good at the maths as well as our
logical thinking only then the scripting
can be executed right and finally once
the execution is being done we need to
go for certain validation so again when
i say validation in the beta stage we'll
be doing some validation where the known
data sets will be given and will be
checking are we getting the expected
results or not
again you might need to fine tune
different
parameters or specifications to reach
the expected value which confirms your
product is good enough
and then the final minimum refinement if
it is needed will be going for this is
specifically for product development as
far as analysis is concerned it's
slightly different we'll be taking a
different data set which has been
already established or have been
published we'll use that same data set
build a pipeline and confirm the results
and then we'll be using the real-time
data set
for uh getting more confident on that
right as far as data management is
concerned we need to know the policies
very well first of all like say
you are a kind of a service provider
where you are building our data
management policies or the products we
need to know the recommend better or
their policies and then we'll be
building the tools again they're also
pretty much the same concept you need to
apply the logic you need to execute it
and you need to validate it and then
you'll be giving the deliverables right
it's pretty much a basic uh benchmark or
probably the bottom scenario which has
to be followed
so the key point here first we need to
be understanding is uh probably the
scope of this particular given problem
and what is the highlight like what do
they want to achieve out of this whole
problem or the product and the last one
is limitation what you can give or what
you can get out of the products and what
are things we can't do it so
the more we know the better we'll be
coming up with the better solutions
that's what the ultimate the probing is
one of the important key this cannot be
done in the middle of the process or the
last
minute rather the more we understand
from the client end or probably it may
be a data or it might be a product the
more we communicate and get the details
from the
given clients the better products we can
achieve
right so this kind of one of the busy
slide with the scary key points to keep
it very simple uh again this slide is
specifically for informatics i would say
if you are a information be it your
analyst or your development site you are
in the basic thing which you need to be
knowing for sure is perl and python of
course there are many cloud computing
services there are uh gui based web
browser there are multiple options are
there but to do a minimum file
manipulation even if you want to do
accounting it's not good to do using a
simple excel so in that case the basic
level of scripting is always recommended
if you are in informatics field again
very basic knowledge
for perl and python at least right
and then before even jumping into the
scripting we need to know the schemes
better like say what is a given problem
which are all how do what are all the
concepts i can apply on the given data
sets and then the systems in this given
configuration or given setup will be
able to execute or not so we need to
know the computation also better with
respect to the scope right so pearl
python is kind of i would say if you are
in informatics field then it is
compulsory and then uh there are next
level of products where people are
nowadays not even notice i would say
down the line uh 10 15 years before also
people are more fond of coding in the
cloud right so where hadoop scala is
kind of widely used if you get a time
and if you are a tech savvy so in case
you are very much fond of
learning the technical skills try to
understand how cloud computing has been
executed where hadoop ecosystem which
covers almost the data management
product development as well as the
uh
full-fledged product development can be
learned in that particular platform
which you can try it out again it's very
very advanced level not for everybody
people who are fond of
tech they can
get into this and the last one which i
am saying is basically next floor why it
is kind it's kind of trendy and it's not
something very new it came from java and
then groovy it's a like third level of
java i would say at this point but why
it is important currently most of the
cloud solutions is getting developed
using this particular scripting so if
you get a chance again if you are very
much fond of tech learning then this is
a thing which you can try it out
as it is trending right
so uh these are all not again compulsory
if you have your own as i told there are
web browsers are there there are windows
based softwares are there there are free
open source tools are there there are
cloud computing services those things
can be explored this is for people who
fond of learning new skills developing
new skills as you have seen the previous
uh
the whole panel was speaking about
developing the skills so if that is a
concept technical skills if you want to
develop being a core developer then
these are all things has to be there as
an analyst if you know bare minimum with
the ball python it's good enough but if
you want to develop something it's
better to have all these things in place
at this given point again down the line
uh in two years this may even get
outdated because the new things that the
way i t
skill requirement is getting uh
probably moving is so faster right so in
this case today this is kind of useful
you'd need to catch up with your skills
always that's what i'm trying to say
from the slide right
so uh switching the gear here
soft skills as far as soft is concerned
almost people have told this i am just
reiterating the same thing a different
way
at certain acting you need to be having
a technical skill for sure but if you
want to survive in the industry the
people's skill is more important yes you
know very well but if you don't know how
to communicate better plus you are not
talking with anybody you are always
working on your own pc it doesn't help
so in that case people skills are very
much important how do you develop you
need to do enough of networking which
has been told before also and you need
to have good contacts again don't run
behind contacts at least if it is
reaching you don't give up like say
someone is coming and talking try to
develop a relation with relations as a
friendly relation with them right and
the team script team split what does
that mean if any given role is uh any
given task
for a team try to distribute instantly
uh
rather than owning the own like taking
the full ownership
try to distribute it so that everyone
get a chance to utilize their skills
right plus you will be also in if you
are working as a team obviously down the
line you will come to know what are the
individual skills as well so that it's
easy to distribute
their their own favorite skill sets so
that's that kind of one kind of thing
which will be understanding in the down
the line right so team spirit is one of
the important thing which gives chance
for the individual growth as well as
well as the team growth as well so
that's one of the important thing which
everyone should be understanding right
and self-discipline which of course
people skill basically if you are very
extrovert
you don't want to work on this first
point because you will be having this
inbuilt right there's no doubt on this
but when it comes intraverse is kind of
different we need to be picking up so
otherwise it's very difficult to survive
right and the second one which is
self-discipline why we are speaking
about self-discipline uh the whole uh
say you are working in office where all
eight hours you are going to communicate
or even if the client comes in with the
requirement you are going to communicate
them the communication is the key again
with respect to what are the words you
use what are the body languages you use
so you are almost communicating or
conveying the message even without
speaking that's what the second point is
which is body language
be it you are giving a talk or you're
sending a mail or you're in the call
like say you are having even one-to-one
conversation everywhere
try to be with the full
self-discipline when i say
self-discipline you need to follow
basic rules which is basically i would
say ground rules which is these things
try to be a lesson
try to have a pleasant conversation as
much as possible and try to spread the
positivity as much as possible and
whenever you speak make sure it's it's
basically your deliver you're delivering
the statement with full confidence and
the way you are delivering people should
get rest on you so that's the ultimate
purpose of communication uh all over be
it professional or non-professional this
should be the way right
and if i want to put it in very simple
term
uh try to
write very clear even simple uh context
so you don't want to be so much of using
a jargons like say very technical terms
even if the simple term would do to
convey the message so try to keep it
very simple second is when we are in
call even though you may you the the
tone is very important the pitch is very
important why people don't see our face
so in that case we need to be very
careful with what we communicate so the
pitch as well as the tone is very very
important in the in the course
specifically right
and the last one is body language
this is mostly for uh if you are working
on your own space there is no issues but
when you are really working as a group
or as a team or even if you are in a
meeting it's very important to maintain
a body language suppose
people can easily figure out who is
basically basically focusing and who is
interested and not interested right so
in that case body language is one of the
important factor
in fact even if if you are speaking and
if your message is conveyed and it may
even reach in the right tub but body
language if it is wrong people
get it very totally different from
altogether so in that case these are all
the key points which has to be followed
these are all the basic i would say
basic recommendations right
so i think
this has been told before right i'm just
putting in a different
context in the
communication as well so we need to know
when i say
scope highlight and
limitations basically
given communication say there is a
communication which happens we need to
grasp the concept quickly so suppose if
someone comes and reaches you for some
topic
try to get the
like say crisp or probably the purpose
behind this quickly and highlight only
the advantages plus try to know the
limitation this i told for the technical
as well this is applicable for the
simple communication as well so rather
than wasting time on unrelevant topics
or like say unwanted things rather
understand the concept as much as
possible try to ask as much as question
in the first instance get a clarity what
why this particular conversation is
happening straight away get to the point
right plus you try to know uh where it
is leading as well as soon as possible
so this is one of the effective way
communication this this is this should
be followed for sure right
as the almost we are in the last part
where the mindset mindset people have
already told also uh since we could able
to see in the panelists there are
different kind of one dollars
there was a consultant there was a
doctor there is a ceo plus there are
information so i we could see almost
different background people in one
particular panel which we saw almost
everyone had kind of same
mindset here so everyone was saying try
to gasp like say grass whatever comes to
you don't miss out any meetings linkedin
be active communicate effectively so
almost they told everything so all
things comes out of one basic thing
which is basically they should have a
very positive mindset plus the eagerness
to learn
with full fash passion right so here i'm
i just brought a little bit of plot
where
try to have experimental mindset
and be ready to take risk again not
extremes at least the basic ones you
should not be giving a second thought
because as a student level it's better
to take a risk at the early stage
because down the line you may not even
getting a chance to take a risk right so
this is a time to take a risk it's
better to take and try to learn things
quickly
again different people have different
learning skill sets probably they may
take a time but
as a motto try to have a motor to learn
quickly so because that is one of the
key factor
to improve the skills faster right and
if anything comes new
you can give a thought let get to know
about pro and cons for sure but
adaptation is one of the important key
factors in index industry because every
company is not going to work in a same
way so it's better to
have a
quick adaptation mindset and then
passion drive and almost everyone will
be having this if they enjoy the job
which they do in that case it's by
default it comes in if you are not
getting it obviously you need to switch
the job so in that case what i meant if
you enjoy the job you don't want to
struggle more on this so passion driven
should be there if you want to uh see a
growth in your career and spread it so
obviously it will be coming in picture
if everything is in place finally the
commitment so if you miss any of these
things in the middle so probably the
commitments should be given to all the
segments which is being shown here
so that's the one which is going to be
driven so it's not like two days you're
doing you are doing something and then
you are living it rather try to have a
long-term commitment with whatever has
been mentioned so uh these are all the
key uh
probably the parameters or the mindset
we should be having it to uh
rather than saying survive to have a
better career in the industry right this
can be applicable for research as well
uh which overall it can be applicable
for both but the skill sets which has
been mentioned or the key points which
has been mentioned is very very
important
if you want to achieve something new
so with that i would like to close the
talk let me see if i have any questions
even though it's very general topic
all right thank you so much
uh mr raja for such
an insightful talk yes we do have some
questions with us that i would like to
ask
so uh one of our participants is asking
uh after requiring technical skills such
as pearl or python
i would like to work on a project using
these skills what are some of the ways
that i can showcase my work
so uh
about the projects again we need to know
as i told before we need to know what
kind of project it is plus
uh we need so again scripting wise you
can always choose any of the scripting
you have c c plus perl java you have
multiple things we need to understand
what is a problem is less which
particular scripting will be best
suitable for the given uh probability to
solve the problem or to develop the
product in that case the more
understanding we should be knowing the
limitations as well as the highlight of
the individual scriptings
probably the programmings
i hope that answers your question
and uh how do you network with experts
in people who are difficult to
communicate with
uh perhaps they're not interested or how
do you convince them
okay so rather than here there is no
convincing rather us she have told very
nicely i think um
uh so don't sit even though linkedin uh
request when you say don't just send a
blank message or a blank invitation you
add in your
key points probably the catchy phrase
when i say catchy place it's not like
like you are putting a one liner to
impress rather you keep something give a
topic which is common between both of
them so of course it may take a time
some people are not open to start a
conversation in the first go right if
you really uh following someone probably
you are you are having passion to follow
someone
keep in touch with them it's not like
you need to communicate down the line
anyway you'll be meeting them if you are
following them seriously
so it's not like you need to force them
to get them in your uh
radar
so you just follow them and do your work
down the line anyway you'll be reaching
them for sure
i mean be optimistic
yeah that's a nice answer all right and
how do the skills require differ while
working on a project individually as
well as by working in a team
that's a nice question
yes
so first of all uh this is this mostly
uh
so let me give a very simple uh explain
like examples first of all when the
project comes in obviously the teams
will be divided individual based on
their skill sets which they have
acquired before even if it if they are
not well trained with the with the skill
sets the team the the individual
division or probably the job
distribution which will be happening
after the project has been settled say
the the business analyst who collects
all the requirement from the clients
then there will be a job distribution
meeting which happens very clearly with
all the team members where based on
their skill sets the the problem will be
different probably the the workload will
be divided so that's one chance where
people even switch or people wants to
learn something new they also get
opportunity so it's kind of well
organized in the mncs when it comes
small startups as people have already
told you will be wearing multiple hats
you will be responsible for multiple
things so in fact you'll be putting your
hands almost everywhere
right and do technology soft skills set
you apart from the crowd
uh
so let me uh change the uh perspective
here
the crowd will be anyway uh will be
following the trending part that's not
sure today one script tomorrow one
script it will be always following right
so in your case
at this point like today you decide like
today you are you are a student so today
you try to pick one skills and try to
become a master down the line say at
least within three years right
why i'm saying this because anyway the
trend will be keep on changing if you
know one script today it's very easy to
adapt new one or you can pick up so
whatever you learned in this three years
can be converted to the new things which
is coming so rather than catching up on
something which is which is basically
keep on running focus on something at
this point for some time and then you
switch it will be easy transition
basically
i hope that answers your question
the okay we have a lot of questions
today how can soft skills provide an
edge to a person in the industry and
what could be some of the tips to
improve them yeah we did cover it
but yeah
if you want to add something
but no i think it's covered it's fine
let's let's yes
okay and as an introvert how can i keep
the conversation going while networking
yes so uh this is this is very very very
difficult for sure but
being introvert is fine still you are in
college and school but when it comes
industry
you will be missing out if you are you
can be an introvert there is no doubt
but when it comes something to your
table like it's example i'm giving
you going running behind someone and
then saying hi is not needed but at
least if you get a high try to say hello
that's minimum requirement which the
introvert should be doing plus if
someone who is matching your wavelength
technically right
be open to discuss with them uh more
so that's one of the thing which i can
think about at this point introvert is
one of the like characteristics which is
a bond skills but there are certain
topics which you should be able to
discuss with people who have same
interest
yeah that's a nice point
and
[Music]
amongst technical and soft skills which
is important
which is more important
so uh
at the early stage technical skills are
very very very very important which is
90 10
and down the line when you are well
experienced with the technical the
people skill should be like 70 percent
important
i hope that answers your question and do
you want to
add something for our participants
towards the end
who are in their graduation and post
graduation and are dealing with their
busy schedule of academics but also want
to upgrade their skill sets but don't
have the time or are confused which
resources to follow what to do how to do
and
actually are confused which specific
skill set to pick they have no idea who
is how can they
yes so uh
some skills again speaking about
academic uh there is a really very good
gap or probably the very long gap from
the academic to industry how do you fill
the gap of course the academic syllabus
where you uh cover for like say the
academic syllabus is only for the scores
right you may grasp up basics for sure
not everyone is picking the life skills
over there when i say life skills it
means the skills which will be useful
for your career and the life right so in
that case
the bridge these bridges can be closed
by taking extra courses it be it might
be either
probably as you can say the mind button
is giving multiple courses
where you get to have extra skills which
your own classmate doesn't have simple
example in your classes 60 people are
there not like everyone knows
how to analyze the ngs data example
right so there are 60 different there
are nearly 16 to 20 different pipelines
which has been developed in the cloud
which they uh pinevitec is having where
every individual pipelines has its own
tools and different parameters you can't
pick up everything in your academic
academic can give you only the
introduction to certain areas they can't
go in deep any of those things so if you
want to
develop your skills you need to take
like you need to come out of the
academic syllabus and learn more outside
the
classrooms which is very important
things that's how we'll be differentiate
from others again there is no
limitations here in the learning the
more you learn outside your class is
going to be helpful in your life like
basically
in the career
so in that case
try to do more this has been already
told before also i am reiterating
conference workshop classes try to
attend more
this improves you
to pick up your skills better